we have the situation where you have the
people who are in power distinctly not
listening to the constituents at all on
any topic on any area of of governance
whatsoever so I think that's what we're
seeing too is we're seeing normal people
be like these lawsuits are bogus you
know mutilating kids is bogus we don't
want any of that opening the borders and
destroying our national sovereignty
that's a terrible idea you know you're
seeing all of this stuff and the more
constituents speak out which they are
doing you know we see the polling we see
all this stuff we see people speaking
out against it and the ruling class
doesn't care at all you know they're so
used to just shoving their elitist
opinions down our throats and I say this
as a you know recovering elitist they
like they're shoving this all down our
throats and we're just supposed to take
it and people don't want to take it
anymore but I do
I do wonder if we're actually winning
like it it feels a lot feels a lot like
being destroyed